this attack on migrants happened ahead
of a big change in Border policy
pandemic error restrictions known as
title 42 will end this week under judges
order U.S officials predict up to 10 000
people a day will try to soon cross the
U.S Mexico border ed O'Keefe is at the
White House Ed good morning Nate good
morning good to see you Homeland
Security insists it's ready for the end
of those pandemic restrictions with 1500
additional troops headed to the border
and new Asylum regulations to be
finalized this week but state and local
officials are raising concerns they may
not have the resources they need
I think we're going to see larger
numbers at first it's going to take our
plan a while to really take hold
Homeland Security secretary Alejandro
mayorkas asking for patience as
officials are planning to deal with the
increased number of Border crossers
expected after title 42 comes to an end
on Thursday we've been preparing for
this for quite some time among other
things DHS is increasing the number of
flights carrying migrants back to their
home countries and those 1500 Military
troops that start arriving at the border
Wednesday will serve in support roles so
Customs and Border Patrol agents can
keep focused on processing those trying
to enter the U.S but Texas Republican
Governor Greg Abbott says it's not
enough we need fifteen thousand or a
hundred and fifty thousand to secure the
Border because of the open border
policies of the byte Administration
Arizona's independent Senator Kirsten
Cinema is introduced a bipartisan bill
that would keep operations similar to
title 42 in place for two more years it
would give Washington time to sort out
tricky issues like border security work
visas and migrant processing it will be
a humanitarian crisis because we are not
prepared but majorcus dismisses that
proposal what we need is our system
fixed right not this Band-Aid solution
as Washington fights over what to do
border cities are bearing the brunt the
mayor of Laredo Texas says his City
doesn't have the money needed to help
care for the number of people expected
to cross soon thousands of people it's
going to be very devastating so that is
our concern right now
one other thing DHS plans to do is
expand appointments for migrants to
apply for Asylum through a mobile app
they've set up but you may recall recent
reporting by 60 Minutes that documented
real frustrations with limitations in
the app and how long it gets how long it
takes to get an appointment either way
Tony a reminder Washington now has to
deal with this issue
yeah it takes years on this side of the
border to get that Asylum hearing if you
make it over Ed thank you very much